My eczema has been flaring up so bad postpartum all over my hands,
on my face,
and if something is wrong with my gut, that usually reflects on my skin,
so I tend to flare up.
I love how taking seed just supports my gut health and fixes things.
I take the DSO1 Daily Synbiotic.
It's a 24 strain probiotic blend
which I've tried a bunch of different probiotics
and I always come back to see
since it's the most effective.
And I see an improvement in my skin when my gut gets healed.
So if anyone is struggling with eczema or other skin problems
or even just floating,
it would be worth it
looking into your gut health and it and trying out a probiotic.
Mmm.